[Music]
look at this place anemone the sun is
shining everybody's out there having fun
makes you want to get out there and join
them doesn't it well I'll see
[Applause]
you now do not forget you are the help
they are the guest your spriter has
arriv finally you got to get out of your
shell buddy come on Armen I'm not like
these other crabs all right I don't
throw my claws in the air oh I don't
wave him like I just don't care Wy wakey
this is for your own good army
but that's go to dance what you got move
girl what did you say to me no no no no
no no that wasn't me that was uh him him
who me me me oh he's so
cute hey look
out oh man where
are man how far are we from the ocean
and in CRA leges I don't know maybe a
million this may be the furthest away
from my mother I've ever been wooo it
feels amazing girl have you lost your
mind oh this my
jam How You Like Me
Now how you doing you know lost and
afraid for my life other than that can't
complain come on open your eyes I liked
it better when they were shut
what are you doing
[Music]
[Applause]
kid it is good to see you out of the
house
Army what do you think they'll think of
us oh
snap are you finished yet c crab cuz
you're standing and not drinking
[Music]
water
n